kim kardashian and pete davidson have
split after nine months of dating now
are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
the pair's romance kicked off with a
kiss last fall when kim hosted saturday
night live and while they kept things
under wraps for a bit the lovey-dovey
social media content eventually surfaced
as did the public appearances
who are you texting ken does his name
rhyme with feet
and we got a peek inside their
relationship on kim's new reality show
the kardashians
pete is has got to be literally the best
human being i've ever met like the best
heart people always say like oh he's so
funny and it's like has to do with how
funny he is that's like
fourth on my list of why i like him
season two premieres this fall and is
expected to show more of their time as a
couple babe yeah do you want to shower
with me really quick
what's your favorite thing about him um
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing i love that
he's kind
and really really thoughtful he's the
most thoughtful person
and i love yeah and i love the chemistry
that kim and him have together it's
really sweet i thought you said the
chemistry i'm just like okay chemistry
chemistry
that can be a new fragrance
but we'll likely have to wait for season
three to see why things ended so soon
just tune in because you never know
what's going to happen
[Music]